[Music]
[Music]
okay okay okay
this is not our show this is definitely
not our show I've done some crazy in my
day once broke the windows IMAX is cheap
in college stabbed Jodi Thompson
successors who's Jody Thompson son Ben
ready mama said I could be anything that
with the dope things in narcotics
robbery homicides bodies drop in like
it's the end the day there's a common
thread to all of us Oh Gabriel knocks
hello
mocha hit me about to go out sure
this is real these people are dangerous
yeah me too
damn it's a party in here I got this
clearly are you wearing blue me trust
each other let me help you
what the hell are you doing here you
don't know what Knox is capable of
I'm not playing good caught tonight I
got a plan
Bad Girls yep
yeah not a perfect track is it we
wouldn't do that
all right we've got a snitch in the
trunk
[Applause]
everything you know is wrong in my
parent
I'm here for you if we go to jail I'm
gonna have to shank you we're gonna have
to get past Roxy I got to deal with this
face first thing I do is wipe up
you